hey hunter walk from homebrew we do a
seed stage investing and I've got a
question for Gary Gary what's up with
virtual reality what's up with virtual
reality
first of all hunter a great background
as you guys can tell hunter was in the
office we're talking Bisbee done some
mutual investing together he's a great
BC a great blogger great Twitter
personality should check him out link
him up during the thing to do something
Dirac to help the dude
anyway hunter it's a great question I
wonder you know it's funny because I
know what you do for a living unlike me
miss hunter looking at this space you
know look I've been talking and I've
been doing this and move and you're
listening I'm putting my hands in my
eyes oculus rift it's coming you know I
very much think that look I mean I hate
predictions but we're having close stay
in the year where I think I'm gonna
force me to do a prediction show when I
say we I mean me I uh 2014 I think by
2024 for sure that's 10 years I think by
2021 VR is gonna really matter I think
video games television and movies
aka entertainment and I don't wanna get
crass but I think porn as well I think
those four categories from a business
standpoint will be heavily affected by
virtual reality and then by virtue i I
see advertising going there because all
of a sudden you can imagine if I'm
playing you know Madden and I feel like
I'm the quarterback and all the signage
around the stadium is now Lionel Richie
root beer wine things of that nature
you can see how advertising gets filled
into it I look I'm in the eyes and ears
business if you want to know what
business I'm in and if you want to get a
cut the rock of a video clip for a 50
second video for my youtube channel take
this one because I'm in once and for all
like stake in the ground I am in the
eyes and ears business wherever the eyes
and ears go I go right if I think the
ears are moving quicker and quicker to
podcasting because connected cars are
here and mobile devices are here I start
podcasting get it it's how I move and so
VR is coming as an investor under the
context of you hunter and asking that
question I am looking at it I'm looking
at the production companies the people
with the kind of 360 cameras that are
going to be in it video game producers
that are gonna play in it I'm a big
believer I think it's a little early
it's definitely early for mass but I
think over the next three years you'll
start seeing kind of like sprinkles to
it and I think five to seven years from
now virtual reality will have a real
place in our society bigger than people
think right now in the way that you
didn't think older people would take
selfies three years ago that's what I
think about VR meaning a lot of you
don't think it's gonna happen I just do
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe